are you ready for an epic showdown in
the vast realm of cyberspace a battle
rages between two formidable forces the
red team and the blue team get ready to
dive into the thrilling world of Red
Team Versus Blue Team cyber threat in
this digital Battlefield cunning hackers
with the red team tactics Clash had on
with the mighty Defenders of the blue
team it's a high stakes game of which
strategy and Cutting Edge technology
with the fate of our online World hangs
in the balance unleashing their arsenal
of hacking skills the red team seeks to
infiltrate breach and expert
vulnerabilities in the digital Fortress
but fear not for the blue TEAM stands
Vigilant on which state of the art
defenses and unwavering determination to
protect our digital realm this Clash of
cyber Titans pushes the boundaries of
innovation and pushes Defenders to their
limits the red teams Relentless attack
serve as a wake-up call revealing
weaknesses that The Blue Team swiftly
fortifies ensuring a strong a more
secure Digital World join us as we
unravel the secrets of the Red Team
Versus Blue Team cyber threat delving
into the tactics the challenges and the
triumphs of those who defend against the
ever-evolving forces of cyber Darkness
get ready to witness a battle where the
only outcome is resilience Innovation
and a safer digital future brace
yourself for the Ultimate Clash of the
Cyber Titans red team vs Blue Team cyber
threat before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a show
to simplyness postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered and if these are the types of
videos you would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press the
Bell icon to never miss any further
content now let's get started first
we'll start the agenda of this tutorial
so first we will start with the
introduction then we'll see what is red
team and then the skill set of red team
and then we'll see what is blue team and
the skill set of blue team then we'll
see the cyber security showdown in which
we will see both the teams how they work
for an organization now we'll see the
introduction that is when it comes to
protecting sensitive data and defending
against cyber threats organizations
employ two teams that is the red team
and the blue team but what do these
teams do and how do they work together
let's find out so we'll start with the
red team the red team also known as the
offensive team it consists of season
Security Professionals who specialize in
mimicking real world attack strategies
their mission is to identify and exploit
vulnerabilities in an organization's
cyber defenses and now we'll see the
advantages of the red team the red team
approach offers several advantages first
it boosts Network safety it helps find
flows in the system encourages
competition and cooperation and
amplifies knowledge on detecting and
stopping cyber results they play a
crucial role in ensuring an
organization's Readiness for prevention
detection and Remediation red team
activities involve thinking like a
hacker to break into a company security
system with permission of course they
perform various tasks such as
penetration testing social engineering
card cloning and intercepting
Communications by constantly challenging
the blue team's defenses the red team
helps improve overall security now we'll
see the skill set of their team members
so to Be an Effective red team member
will need skills in software expertise
penetration testing and social
engineering understanding the risk and
creatively strategizing attacks are
essential to overcome the blue team's
defenses now see the certificate
questions that could be the add-ons for
a red team member aspiring red team
professionals can enhance their
credentials through certification such
as certified ethical hacker CH giac
penetration tester licensed penetration
tester offensive security certified
professional and certified red team
operations professional the
certification demonstrate expertise in
offensive security and penetration
testing now we'll see what is a blue
team now we'll shift our Focus to the
blue team that is also known as the
defensive team their primary role is to
maintain an organization's internal
Network defenses against cyber attacks
the work tirelessly to protect valuable
assets detect threats and respond
swiftly to any security breaches now see
their activities so what do they do so
the blue team is responsible for
analyzing digital traces auditing the
domain name system constructing
firewalls monitoring Network traffic and
employing access controls their name is
to establish a strong security posture
and prevent unauthorized access now we
will see the skill set of blue team
member so to Be an Effective member of
the blue team one must possess skills in
risk and suspend threat intelligence and
hardening techniques they work with
intrusion prevention systems inclusion
detection system and other security
software to defend against cyber attacks
now we'll see the certifications that
will be the add-on for beauty members so
certifications like compare Security
Plus giac certified incident Handler
certified Information Systems auditor
giac Security Essential certification
system security certified practitioner
Advanced security practitioner and
certified Information Systems security
professional these can help blue team
professionals enhance their defensive
security expertise and the red team and
The Blue Team must collaborate
effectively to ensure optimal security
The Exchange information about emerging
dangers and hacker techniques enabling
both teams to stay one step ahead
however in some cases the blue team may
not be informed so the red team and The
Blue Team must collaborate effectively
to ensure optimal security now we'll see
the cyber security showdown in which we
will see how they operate now we'll dive
into the intense showdown between the
red team and the blue team now picture
this the red team launches a
sophisticated attack on the
organization's Network attempting to
breach its defenses and gain
unauthorized access to sensitive data
now the red team utilizes their Advanced
skills that is penetration testing
social engineering and exporting
vulnerabilities to carry out their
attack their goal is to infiltrate the
network and extract valuable information
without getting caught on the other side
the blue team is constantly Vigilant
monitoring Network traffic analyzing
security logs and endpoint Advanced
defensive measures their objective is to
detect and prevent any unauthorized
access and swiftly respond to any
security breaches as the red team
progresses through the network they
encounter various obstacles put in place
by The Blue Team firewalls intuition
detection systems and other security
measure challenges there every move but
the red team is persistent utilizing
their expertise to find loopholes and
exploit weaknesses meanwhile The Blue
Team closely monitors the red team's
attack patterns analyzing their
techniques and reinforcing their
defenses in real time they actively
collaborate sharing information and
strategizing to mitigate the ongoing
threat the main objective as the red
team is to help organizations identify
vulnerabilities in their systems by
simulating real world attacks they
provide valuable insights that enable
The Blue Team to enhance their defensive
capabilities and the red team plays a
crucial role in cyber security strategy
their simulated attacks push blue team
to the limits and reveal weaknesses the
red team plays a crucial role in our
cyber security strategy their simulated
attacks push us to the limits that is
push blue team to the limits and reveal
weaknesses that they might otherwise
Overlook it's a constant pattern but it
helps them stay prepared and strengthen
their defenses ultimately the red team
and The Blue Team rely on collaboration
and mutual respect to succeed while the
red team exposes vulnerabilities the
blue team's role is to learn from their
experiences adapt their defenses and
continuously improve the organization's
overall security posture with that we
have reached the end of this tutorial
let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers hi I'm Philip
I'm 61 years old and last year iobscure
with simple Learners post program at
cyber security after working 30 years in
the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
will able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
on our first if you have any questions
please feel free to comment and we'll
have it answered for you as soon as
possible until next time thank you for
watching stay safe keep learning and get
ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign